HAPPY NEWS EVERYBODY. IT IS
GREAT TO SEE YOU. LET'S GET
RIGHT TO IT. TONIGHT'S MONOLOGUE
IS ALL AND GENDER, IS THAT
RIGHT, ELVIS?
♪♪
>> YOU KNOW WHEN I SUGGESTED HEY
LET'S PLAY RETURN TO SENDER BUT
IT IS "RETURN TO GENDER," I
EXPECT SOME VERSES. THEY
LITERALLY JUST SAY "RETURN TO
GENDER," THAT'S ALL THEY DID. I
AM NOT GOING TO SAY THEY NAIL IT
IN BUT I AM GOING TO SAY THEY
MAIL IT IN. I BEGIN WITH THE
47-YEAR-OLD SINGLE FATHER, RENEE
SELENES OF ECUADOR. NOT TO BE
CONFUSED OF THE GUY. RENEE
CHANGED HIS GENDER TO FEMALE.
THAT'S SMART. NOT JUST TO EXCUSE
HIS LOUSY DRIVING.
>> OH, TEXAS, WOULD SAY --
>> IS IT REALLY THAT FUNNY,
EMIL
EMILY?
>> YES, GOOD.
>> WHY WOULD RENEE DO THIS? HE
ALREADY HAD A CHICK'S NAME. THE
COURT SYSTEM WHICH I EXPERIENCED
WHICH IS MY CHILD, ENRIQUE. I AM
ONLY SEEN AS A PROVIDER, WHAT I
AM LOOKING FOR IS TO GIVE THE
LOVE AND PROTECTION THAT A
MOTHER GIVES HER CHILDREN.
EXCUSE ME, MOTHER? EVERY HERE WE
CALL IT BIRTHING PERSON. YOU
DISGUSTING, TRANS-PHOBIC PIG.
RENEE DIDN'T GO OUT TO GET A WIG
LIK
LIKE
KI
GE
GET MY
LIK
KI
GE
GET M
GET M.
RENEE LIVES HIS DAY-TO-DAY AS A
MAN BECAUSE HE IS ONE. HIS LBGTQ
ACTIVISTS CALLING HIS ACTION
OUTLANDIS
OUTLANDISH WHICH
QUESTION WHAT'S INLANDISH? I
DON'T KNOW. I WISH I HAD THAT
MUCH IMUCH INGENUITY TO SEE M
CHILDREN. IT IS SO CUTE WHEN
THEY WORK THROUGH THE NIGHT. NOW
ONTO TRANSGENDER SWIMMER, ISAAC
HEMIC. HE'S BORN FEMALE BUT IS
NOW A MALE IN COMPETING OF THE
YALE TEAM.
SHRINKAGE IS A CAUSE FOR
CONCERN. YOU NOTICE THESE THINGS
NEVER HAPPEN IN SCHOOLS LIKE
DEVRY'S. I GUESS YOU DON'T HAVE
SPORTS PROGRAM WHEN EVERY
ATHLETE MISSES A FINGER. FOR A
SWIMMER, HE TOTALLY SUCKED.
HE WROTE IN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," "INSTEAD I AM TRYING TO
CONNECT WITH MY TEAMMATES IN NEW
WAYS TO CHEER LOUDLY AND FOCUS
MORE ON THE EXCITEMENT OF THE
SCORE," EXCUSE ME, IS THAT
SOMETHING CALL LIKE THE
CHEERLEADER? I COULD HAVE SAVED
YOU A WHOLE LOT OF TIME.
>>
WOW, AT LEAST ISAAC WAS ONCE
A WOMAN AND NOW A MAN LOST TO
NEARLY EVERY MAN. THIS IS
DIFFERENT FROM SWIMMERLY
AUTONOMOUS WHO USED TO BE A MAN
AND NOW A WOMAN. ISAAC IS
DIFFERENT. THIS GENDER CHANGE
TOOK HER FROM BEING THE TOP TO
BEING FROM THE BOTTOM. ONLY FOUR
DUDES FINISHED AFTER HIM AND ONE
OF THEM HAD ONLY ONE ARM.
SHOUTOUT TO LEFTY. TWO CASES OF
GENDER BANNING NO HARM AND NO
FOUL. THE ECUADOR DAD WANTED TO
SEE HIS KIDS AND PERHAPS, HE
WATCHED "MRS. DOUBTFIRE" TOO
MANY TIMES. THESE STORIES OF
GENDER MAKES NO SENSE. THIS
FINAL ONE DOES NOT. IT NEVER
DOES. GET A LOAD OF THIS DOLL
FACE, HE'S A CONVICTED SEX
OFFENDER OF CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN.
HE ALSO WENT BY KYLE BAILEY, GET
THIS, NOW HE'S BRANDY WOOD. YES,
BRANDY WOOD. PROVEN THAT
CRIMINALS USE NAME GENERATORS
JUST LIKE THE REST OF US. WL
TALK ABOUT THAT LATER. BRANDY IS
IDENTIFIED AS AN INTER-SEX
FEMALE AND WANTS TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO A WOMEN'S
FACILITY. I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT
VICTORIA'S SECRET. AN
M
.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS. THE THOUGHTS IN HIS HEAD
ARE SO DIRTY THAT HIS OWN HAIR
RAN AWAY. COMEDIAN ON SIRIUS XM,
JIM NORTON.
>> SHE TALKS SO FAST, I KEEP ON
THINKING I AM SUPPOSED TO BID ON
A COW. EMILY COMPAGNO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SHE'S NEVER BEEN ASKED TO
BABYSIT. FOX CONTRIBUTOR, KAT
TEMP.
>> AND MY HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION,
TYRUS.
>> JIM, FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT SAY HAPPEN
PI NEW YEAR TO MY DEAR FRIEND. I
AM HAPPY TO SEE YOU.
>> I AM SO GLAD THAT YOU ARE ONE
OF THE FEW PEOPLE THAT KNEW MY
NAME.
>> I DID. I WAS SURPRISED. OH,
RIGHT, GOT IT. I HAVE AN ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION, BY THE WAY. I
AM PROMOTING A THREE-CITY TOUR
ON FRIDAY. I AM IN DALLAS AND ON
SUNDAY, I WILL BE IN LANDISH.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU DECIDED TO
PIGGYBACK ON A JOKE.
>> I KNOW, I MADE IT WORSE.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE WHOLE
PRISON THING? AND IT IS LIKE WHY
CAN PEOPLE IN WHO IN
ADMINISTRATIVE JOBS NOT SEE THIS
IS OBVIOUS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, TOM HANK'S
ROOMMATES AND BUDDY, I CAN
UNDERSTAND. I GET WHY YOU WOULD
WANT TO DO THIS. IT IS A
BRILLIANT STRATEGY. IF I WAS IN
PRISON, I AM A LADY, OKAY, GO TO
THE WOMAN'S PRISON.
>> YEAH, YOU ARE LESS LIKELY
BEATEN UP AND PROBABLY GET
BEATER MEALS AND THE HYGIENE IS
NOTHING TO LAUGH AT, RIGHT,
EMILY? YOU HAVE BEEN TO JAIL.
YOU ARE A LAWYER, THAT'S CLOSE
ENOUGH. IS THAT IS FAIR AND WHAT
THE FATHER DOING FAIR TO THE
MOTHER BY CHANGING HIS GENDER
BUT NOTHING ELSE ABOUT HIMSELF?
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE THIS BECAUSE
TLES NOTHING FAIR ABOUTS THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WEIGHS SO
HEAVILY OF GENDER OVER
EVERYTHING ELSE. ECUADOR IS
SIMILAR TO CALIFORNIA IN THAT
THE PRESUMPTION TO OVERCOME THAT
WAY IS SO STRONG, IT IS IN THE
LACK OF FAVOR FOR THE DAD WHERE
I HAVE SEEN CASES AFTER CASES
WHERE THE INJUSTICE IS JUST
APPARENT. FOR GOOD DADS THAT
JUST WANT TO SPEND TIME WITH
THEIR KIDS. HE'S CALLING OUT THE
SYSTEM FOR WHAT IT IS. IT IS A
BOX THAT'S BEEN CHECKED AND THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM IS A CHOOSER
ADVENTURE. THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
GOES TOWARDS PRESUMPTION OF
FAVOR FOR THE MOTHER FOR
EVERYTHING. SO STATEMENTS THAT
THE MOTHER MADE WILL HAVE THE
SAME WEIGHT. THE STACK AGAINST
THE MALE IS PATENTLY UNFAIR. I
LIKE THIS AND SIMILAR TO THE
PRISON THING OF WHAT OUR TAX
DOLLARS IS PAID FOR. THE SYSTEM
IS SET UP RIGHT NOW IS A JOKE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS GOT CALLED OUT
AND THE FACT OF THE SEX CHANGE
IN PRISON AND THE HANNA TUB, YOU
REMEMBER HER/HIM, THAT WAS
HORRIFYING.
I AM GLAD IT IS COMING TO LIFE.
THIS SHOULD LOBBY THE PUBLIC TO
TELL OUR CONGRESSMEN TO CHANGE
THE LAWS. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> I DON'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES." THE FIRST
TRANS PERSON ON DEATH ROW WAS
EXECUTED LIKE TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> YEAH, THE OTHER DAY.
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER THIS IS VERY
RARE FOR A WOMAN TO DIE ON DEATH
ROW. THE PERSON WHO COMMITTED
THE CRIME WAS A MAN, BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT,
TYRESE. WHAT'S YOUR FEELING?
>> WELL, THEY'RE NOT ALONE.
>> I THINK I SPEAK TO EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM THAT I DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THIS BUT SINCE WE
ARE GOING TO DO THIS. IT IS
FUNNY WHAT THEY GET UPSET ABOUT.
IT IS OKAY FOR THEM TO GAIN THE
SYSTEM.
WHEN A MAN DOES IT WHO'S
FIGHTING FOR HIS CHILDREN WHO HE
HAD NOT SEEN IN MONTHS AND AN
ARTICLE WHERE THERE WAS A LOT OF
ABUSE ON THE OTHER SIDE. HS
DOING OUT OF DESPERATION,
WILLING TO CHANGE HIS GENDER ON
HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE AND TRY TO
GET A FAIR SHAKE IN COURT. YOU
KNOW ONCE HE GOES TO COURT, THE
JUDGE IS GOING TO ATTACK HIM FOR
TRYING TO GAIN THE SYSTEM WHICH
ULTIMATELY HE'LL END UP IN THE
SAME SITUATION. FOR MEN, THEY'RE
GOING TO REMIND THEM THAT HE'S A
MAN.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHO'S TRYING TO DO THIS TO
GAIN THE SYSTEM.
BUT, THEY WON'T DO IT FOR MEN
WHO COMMIT CRIMES.
>> EXACTLY TO GAIN THE SYSTEM.
>> SO, IF I GO TO JAIL AND I SAY
WELL, ACTUALLY, I AM IDENTIFIED
AS A WOMAN --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I AM NOT SAYING ANYTHING.
>> AND ONCE I GET IN
THERE -- WITHIN SIX TO EIGHT
MONTHS IT IS GOING TO BE A WHOLE
NE
NEW
GE
G'S RUNNING ALL OVER THE PLACE,
YOU ARE LOCKED UP ALL DAY, YOU
KNOW? WHAT ELSE ARE YOU GOING TO
DO?
>> IT IS TRUE.
>> NO ONE WOULD GAIN THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE I AM A CRIMINAL.
HERE IS THE SILVER LINING IN
THIS THING. WHEN THIS HAPPENS
AND CRIMES START HAPPENING TO
WOMEN IN PRISON THEN THEY'LL DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THEY WON'T
DO IT IN COLLEGE SPORTS OR MEN
FIGHTING FOR THEIR KIDS. WHEN HE
GOES IN THERE AND HE STARTS
HURTING PEOPLE THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY'LL BE LIKE THIS IS
NOT GOOD FOR US AND WE ARE
GETTING TOO MUCH ATTENTION. THEY
CARE MORE ABOUT CRIMINALS THAN
REGULAR PEOPLE.
>> YOU NAILED IT. THANK YOU.
KAT. I HAD NO IDEA ECUADOR IS
NEAR THE EQUATOR.
>> YEAH.
>> I DIDN'T. DID YOU?
>> OKAY, I AGREE WITH TYRUS THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK FOR
EMA
R
RENEE. I HAVE NOT BEEN TO
ECUADOR BUT I HAVE BEEN TO THE
WIKIPEDIA PAGE TODAY.
>> IT SAYS SAME-SEX COUPLES CAN
ADOPT KIDS.
>> THAT'S EVERYONE WORSE FOR
THIS GUY? HE DID SUCCEED IN THE
NOBLE SUIT OF GETTING ATTENTION
WHICH I CAN'T BLAME HIM THERE.
>> WE ARE ONE SHOW THAT'S
COVERING THIS.
>> I AM NOT SHOCKED BY THAT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW. FOR THE
PRISONERS, TOO, INNER SEX IS AN
ACTUAL, BIOLOGICAL THING SO THIS
PERSON DOES NOT KNOW THE SYSTEM
WELL ENOUGH TO TRY TO GAME IT.
THIS PERSON IN ADDITION TO BE A
CRIMINAL IS KIND OF STUPID.
>> YEAH, THIS PERSON GOT IN
TROUBLE FOR TALKING TO PEOPLE
ONLINE AS INNER-SEX, I THINK
THEY SAID HE HAD AN OUTFIT HE
WAS WEARING WHICH WAS WAY TOO
HIGHLY PRICED. IT WAS A WOMAN'S
OUTFIT.
>> INTERESTING.
>> DID HE MENTION WHERE HE GOT
THAT?
>> ECUADOR. HE GOT IT IN
ECUADOR.
>> I THINK YOU CAN FIND IT I